this morning more than a hundred British
police officers are searching for what
may have contained the nerve agent that
critically injured two people in a small
English town investigators are still
trying to establish how the victims were
exposed to the lethal substance before
collapsing Charlie d'Agata is outside
the hospital in Salisbury Charlie good
morning we've learned that the couple
still being treated here in critical
condition picked up what police are
calling a contaminated item what we
don't know is where and more importantly
if there's any more out there security
camera footage has emerged showing
poisoning victim Don Sturgis the day
before she fell gravely ill buying
alcohol first summer's evening unaware
that within 24 hours both she and
partner Charlie Rolly would be fighting
for their lives after being exposed to
the deadly nerve agent Nova Chuck the
same kind of toxin used in the poisoning
of double agent Sergei scribble and his
daughter Yulia four months ago
roley's brother is still struggling to
comprehend what's happened he's my love
in space I don't think anything's
happened to him what's not known or
police won't say is where the couple
came into contact with the nerve agent
today police are scouring areas in a
race to figure out where that nerve
agent came from before it harms anyone
else they've sealed off six sites by
this morning they had erected new
barriers around roly's house worryingly
the public had been warned not to pick
up any foreign objects though a local
health official was in no mood to
elaborate but it suggests that there
might be something out there that they
shouldn't be touching in relation to
what's going on now well I think we are
working with the best information we've
got available and I just like to keep
reiterating we've only seen two members
of the public come forward with symptoms
that require treatment only two people
in critical condition exposed to
military-grade nerve agent somewhere not
exactly a reassurance to people we spoke
to this is a quiet little town so you
wouldn't think this would happen here
maybe sharpen that really yeah a bit of
a shock to say the least but if there is
a positive hospital officials here say
no unit is better qualified to treat
these victims after all this team has
been through it all before for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata Salisbury
England Charlie d'Agata thanks for that
update Charlie